off season everyone's been talking about
Aaron Rogers coach Salah he's been
planning to have Aaron Rogers that team
wasn't getting built for Zach Wilson yes
he was in training camp but no one was
expecting him to play he probably wasn't
taking the same reps get the same looks
SK everything like Aaron Rogers was and
now they're trying to adjust and limit
the system and come back to a new system
and is being compared to Hall of Famer
which isn't fair he needs time to grow
if it was so easy a bunch of people
could be quarterback this isn't a walk
in the park job quarterback is one of
the hardest positions in the NFL and you
expect a third-year guy who got benched
last year say hey we're going to take
Aaron Rogers his team needs to give back
to him they need to pour into him so he
could be the guy they want to
be